[Music]
Well, hello everyone. Thank you for
joining our program. I'd like to know
this is a weekly program where uh
viewers send in their questions and we
do the research and try to find answers
to life's most pressing questions.
We'd be glad to have the questions uh
that you have sent to us. Let me give
you the email address where you can send
them. It's tvsumtv.org.
TV tvsumtv.org.
We would be delighted to receive your
questions. I have with me uh Pastor
Danielle Miranda. Uh he came to us from
Colombia and his wife Kelly also works
here at Secrets Unsealed. We're so
pleased and blessed to have you here
with us and thank you for being here for
the program. I'd like to know.
Amen. It is a pleasure for me to be here
and to learn from experience.
Amen. Well, uh we should uh do first
things first and the first thing that we
should do is have prayer. Amen.
Ask the Lord to bless our session today.
So, as is customary, would you please
pray for the Lord's presence?
I will. Let's pray. Heavenly Father, we
thank you for this new program of I like
to know. Thank you for those who have
sent in their questions and thank you
because this is an opportunity for us to
research to study our Bibles and we do
not pretend to know all the answers but
we pray that you may help us to the best
of our abilities to give correct answers
to these questions. We pray all this in
the name of Jesus. Amen.
Amen. Well, we have a question here that
is very very interesting.
Um, this of course is probably a
question that was formulated by a 7th
Day Adventist is my guess.
Most assuredly
and I'll read the question and then I'll
send uh the question to you for you to
answer.
Okay.
Uh the question is this just a short
question. We must follow Jesus.
But did Jesus eat fish? So can we eat
fish like him?
So, should we follow in his steps by
eating fish the way Jesus ate fish?
Well, in order for me to answer that
question with a yes or a no, I have to
say several things before. Number one,
the Bible is given to us in principle.
Uh, principles do not change, precepts
change.
So, the plant-based diet
is a precept, but the principle is
health behind a plant-based diet. Why do
we say that that is not the principle?
Well, because the principle change that
the precept changes with time and
circumstances and we know that later on
after the flood, God gave permission to
humanity to partake of clean animals. So
we see that God himself even
accommodated to the circumstances and uh
gave precepts according to those
circumstances. Now when Jesus came to
this earth, Jesus uh the Bible says in
Galatians that Jesus was made under the
law
and the law in Jesus's time did not
prohibit the eating of clean animals
and fish was considered a clean animal.
So Jesus was not breaking any particular
thing of the law. Now when we go to
Jesus himself as a person even in his
life we all know that we need to follow
Jesus but um what aspect specifically
are we to follow every specific aspect
of Jesus and uh and I don't want to be
controversial with this question. I'm
not trying to say that we should not
follow Jesus. But for example, let's
take Jesus. Jesus never married.
Does that mean that we are not supposed
to marry?
Good question.
Jesus never had children.
So if we need to follow Jesus, does that
mean that we are not supposed to have
children? Jesus wore a simple garment
all the way down to the foot, white
garment. Are we supposed to dress like
him? I know with these questions are
easy to answer because that was in the
in in his time for example that's the
way they dressed uh Jesus had a specific
ministry and it didn't require him to
get married but that doesn't forbid
marriage he even himself taught
sure
about marriage and the sanctity of
marriage same thing with this Jesus and
Ellen White explains it real really
clear in the chapter about the feeding
of the thousand of the 5,000 she says
that Jesus could have provided banquet
for the multitudes, but he provided the
simplest food that was available, the
food of uh of the common people
that was healthy and nourishing. That's
what she says,
right?
So, of the best options that were in
Jesus's context, this was the healthiest
option.
Yeah.
You know, and fish back then were not uh
sick and polluted as the fish today. And
I believe you're going to comment on
that as well. So that is the precept
that is the principle. So today for
example as seventh day adventists we
have given we have been given more light
in regards to the issue of meat eating
including fish. But even in Ellen Y
herself we see that that was a progress
and a development even after Ellen White
said that we are not supposed to eat
meat. She occasionally ate meat until
the 90s uh where she was in Australia
that uh there was a woman that came to
him, a Catholic woman, and kneelled
before her and she said, "Why would you
why do you eat or why do you kill the
lives of animals and partake of that?
You're doing wrong to God's creation."
Another wife was thinking about it and
she says, "I will no longer do it."
And she says that that was a rebuke to
her. Since then she quit all animal
flesh but she continue even eating fish
until early 20th century. She later quit
also fish because of the pollution in
the waters. Right.
So but she never made this issue a test
question in our church.
Yeah. And the bottom line is that some
things that God allowed in the past
uh I think that today he would not
allow.
Right.
uh the animal world is a lot sicker
now than it was back in the times of
Christ. And uh you know God said that
there were certain kinds of clean
animals that human beings could eat in
the Old Testament. You know um of the
land animals you have split hoof and uh
chew the cut.
Uh fish they have to have fins and
scales and birds that are not birds of
prey. They're domestic birds. uh th
those could be eaten. Um you know some
people say well God gave permission to
eat those things and so we can eat them
until the until Jesus comes using what
the Bible says.
But when circumstances change
God's counsel also changes.
Exactly.
And that's why Ellen White does not
contradict the Bible when she says that
we should leave all flesh foods. Not
just the the flesh foods that the Bible
forbids but all flesh foods. She says be
those who are preparing for the second
coming need to leave all of them.
Mhm.
Even though the Bible says that there's
certain clean foods that supposedly you
can eat. And the reason why is because
uh the the animal world is a lot sicker
that uh now than it used to be. And
furthermore, we're preparing for the
society of heaven.
Amen.
God is not going to change our tastes on
the way to heaven.
Exactly. We have to learn to eat the
original diet that God established in
the Garden of Eden, which is a vegan
diet. You can read it in Genesis chapter
1 and verse 29. So God gave Israel a
plan B,
which is clean animals.
Ellen White says, "Well, let's go back
to plan A."
Amen.
Besides, uh, Israel could not raise
crops in the wilderness. First of all,
the wilderness doesn't produce crops.
And secondly, because it would take a
long time for those crops to grow. And
so, and so God allowed Israel to partake
of clean meats, uh, which by the way was
did not exist first of all in the times
of Moses, but goes all the way back to
the time before the flood, right?
Because Mo Noah took clean and unclean
animals into the ark.
Correct? uh so when circumstances change
God's counsel changes uh in order to be
in harmony with uh the situation at the
time
and you have complimented my answer
because we started saying that about uh
principles don't change but precepts
changed according to the circumstances
and so like God did after the flood that
he allowed he gave a temporary
permission to man to eat flesh uh food
in the same time today in In our last
days, as you say, the uh animal world is
sicker and we should abstain from all
flesh foods as much as we can.
Yeah.
Uh not only for spiritual reasons, but
also for health reasons.
Yeah. You know, one of the tragedies and
the things that something that keeps my
wife awake at night is thinking about
all the chickens that suffer
a a cruel death,
right? And what they do is they inject
hormones into the chickens so that they
grow so much faster so they can go to
market. It's millions and millions and
millions of chickens because it seems to
be the most common type of meat that
people eat. And uh you know just to
satisfy an appetite that that I would
say is perverted
because it's so much better to partake
of what God naturally created to be
eaten at the very beginning. the
beginning is the standard. Uh you know
God allowed divorce among the Israelites
because of the hardness of their hearts.
But Jesus said no that that's not the
standard. Says at the beginning it was
not so. So we need to return to the
beginning as we choose a place to live
in the country. We need to go back to
the beginning when it comes to diet. We
need to go back to the beginning when it
comes to the Sabbath. We need to go back
to the beginning when it comes to
marriage. We need to go back to the
beginning when it comes to gender
distinctions, two genders, male and
female. We need to go back to the
beginning for everything.
Amen.
Because that is God's plan A.
Very much so.
Okay. So, I think we're ready for the
next question, right?
Yes. I think it's a complicated one.
Yes.
It's like the question that the
Sadducees asked Jesus a little bit
similar,
right?
Okay. Henry Timothy
I was married.
I divorced and remarried.
I am now widowed. The remarried wife is
deceased within the context that I am
the offending
uh the wrong party. Is it offer under
God to marry the third time? Is
remarrying a third time an unpardonable
evil based on some popular SDA teachers?
So here if the first marriage he doesn't
give the reasons why he divorced the
first time.
Well he said uh I'm the offender.
But I'm the offender party. So yes most
likely it was adultery I would think.
Okay. Um well he he was not allowed to
remarry the second time
right?
But he did anyway.
But that sp but that spouse died.
But that spouse died. But the first
spouse, uh, we kind of insinuate that
it's still alive. So, can he remarry
someone else other than his first wife?
Well, if his first wife is alive,
um, Jesus said that u the the person
that marries,
he that commit adultery also commits
adultery.
Right? So, so basically you know Ellen
White gave some very wise counsel. She
said if one of the one of the
individuals commits adultery
the best plan is not a divorce. The best
plan is to try and work things out
and rebuild the marriage.
Yes. Now I don't know the circumstances
of the first marriage what the reason
why although you kind of assume that uh
that he's he says I'm the offending
party. Uh but the ideal would have been
to uh restore that marriage.
Amen.
But it's water on the bridge. It was not
restored. So the question is did his
first wife remarry?
Because that that would determine
whether he has the freedom to remarry or
not.
Exactly.
Um but as far as this being an
unpardonable evil,
uh would we go that far to say that it
would be an unpardonable evil?
It is not an unpardonable evil. There is
forgiveness for this. And um there is
grace and God can still restore you.
There is grace, sufficient grace and
forgiveness from God. So even though
this might be a terrible sin, this sin
can be forgiven and can be overcome and
Jesus can restore you to uh your
forgiven state. Uh he can give you his
righteousness and you can be justified
by faith.
And that's the good news. Yes.
That God is a God of grace. We make
mistakes in our lives.
God does not hold those mistakes against
us.
Amen. As long as we repent, he does not
hold those mistakes against us forever.
As long as we live, because then we
would live in misery. We would live
unhappy lives all of our life if we
didn't have this the assurance that
God's grace and God's forgiveness could
be ours.
Amen. Now, I believe if I remember well,
we had a program many months ago on
specifically on remarage.
And it would be good if you go back to
our program where we unpack in more
detail this issue about when to remarry,
reasons for divorce and things like
that.
So um you can download our app and there
you you will be able to find all the
programs with the questions that have
been answered and also you can go to our
YouTube channel and see there the videos
that have been posted. Yeah, this is
actually a good opportunity to encourage
all of those who are watching to uh
download Yes. not only our Secrets
Unsealed app, but also our Sum TV app
uh because we have two apps and they're
totally free
and uh our new app is phenomenal. You
can actually download or view every
single one of the presentations that we
have ever produced here at Secrets
Unsealed for free. You see, our ministry
is not a ministry that has the purpose
of making money. Uh, at first, of
course, we uh, and this just kind of a
parenthesis, at first, you know, the
only way that we could sustain the
ministry when we were just beginning was
through sales because we were basically
unknown. But as time has gone by, uh,
our sales have, uh, diminished as
compared to our donations. uh as of now
95%
of our income is based on donations.
Only 5% is based on sales. And uh so we
decided that we would put everything
available for everybody because the
purpose is to extend the message. Amen.
The purpose isn't uh for the ministry to
to make money. The purpose is to get the
message out to as many people as
possible. And we appreciate the
financial support that people give us
here at Secrets Unsealed and some TV
because it does cost significant sums of
money to have the personnel and to have
the equipment necessary to produce the
programming that we do. So we do
appreciate donations from those who
support our ministry.
Amen.
Okay. Now we have um another question
and this has to do with the Holy Spirit
in the Old Testament.
Um, and basically this is the question.
Hello, I have a question. What is the
difference between the work of the Holy
Spirit in the Old Testament and after
the resurrection of Jesus? Clearly the
Holy Spirit has always been active in
the world. And then this person provides
uh verses Genesis 6:3, the Lord said,
"My spirit should not always shall not
always strive with man." Proverbs 1:23,
"Turn you at my reproof. Behold, I will
pour out my spirit unto you. I will make
known my words unto you. And then
Zechariah 4:6. Then he answered and
spake unto me, saying, This is the word
of the Lord unto Zerubbabible, saying,
not by might nor by power, but by my
spirit, saith the Lord of hosts. And it
says, "And so many more." And yet the
Bible says that the Holy Spirit had was
not had not yet been given
uh in the New Testament yet before
Pentecost. It says in John 7:39, "But
this he spake of the spirit which they
that believe on him should receive for
the Holy Ghost was not yet given because
that Jesus was not yet glorified." And
then John 16:13, Jesus says, "How be it
when he the spirit of truth is come." So
it seems like the Holy Spirit was
already working in the Old Testament. So
why uh does it say that G that um here
in particularly John 7:39
uh this he spake of the spirit which
they should believe in him would receive
for the Holy Ghost was not yet given.
So if it work was working in the Old
Testament, how is it was it that it
wasn't given until Pentecost?
I'd like to quote John uh chapter 3:34
and maybe uh we can extract a principle
from here trying to understand this
here. This is uh John the Baptist
speaking of course written by John the
Apostle. It says we're going to read
from verse 23 uh 33 actually. He who has
received his testimony has certified
that God is true. For he whom God has
sent speaks the words of God. For God
does not give the spirit by measure.
Mhm.
So John here is saying that Jesus had
received the spirit without measure.
That means that the spirit has always
been working but in some people with
measure but at Pentecost the spirit was
given without measure upon the
disciples. And there were some Pentecost
experiences in the in the in the Old
Testament. For example, uh you might
remember in I think this is numbers 11
if I'm not wrong when Moses appoints the
70 and the Holy Spirit fell upon them.
They were prophesying and um and Joshua
said, "Hey, master, you know, they're
prophesying there and and and Moses
tells Joshua
uh that uh he rebukes Joshua for for not
uh for making that comment. In other
words, it was God's will for them to
prophesy." We have for example in the
school of the prophets that even Saul
would send his enemies after David and
that when they would go there they would
prophesy. The Holy Spirit fell upon
them. Even Saul himself
he ended up prophesying. Same Elijah on
Mount Carmel. He made fire come down
from heaven. So those were moments where
the Holy Spirit was really poured out
without measure. But uh when we come
here John 7:39
you know Jesus says it is convenient for
me to leave if I don't go then the Holy
Spirit would not come.
Yeah.
When Jesus came personally
um the work of the Holy Spirit is too
direct to Jesus. But when Jesus was
personally here on earth the work of the
Holy Spirit I would say was limited
because Jesus was with them. But when
Jesus would leave again the Holy Spirit
will be poured out upon the disciples.
I also think that you have to look at
the relationship between the type and
the anti-ype. Mhm.
Uh in the Old Testament uh there's a
certain phenomenon that sacrifice was
offered and then fire from God fell to
consume the sacrifice
that represented the fact the sacrifice
of course represents the fact that Jesus
was going to die on the cross. And
because he died on the cross, he was
able to pour out the Holy Spirit who
came manifesting himself as tongues of
fire. That's right. So in the Old
Testament uh the Old Testament type of
the day of Pentecost was the type.
Mhm.
But the Holy Spirit to which the type
pointed actually is fulfilled when the
Holy Spirit is poured out on the day of
day of Pentecost. So it's like kind of
like the lamb in the Old Testament. The
lamb represented Christ. People were
going to look forward to the moment when
Christ would die. Well, the same
Pentecost pointed forward to the time
when the Holy Spirit was going to be
poured out, as you said, without measure
on the day of Pentecost. So, it's the
relationship between Pentecost in type
and Pentecost and antitype, which is the
total and complete fulfillment of what
Pentecost represents.
Amen.
All right. Uh let's notice the next
question comes from Andrew G
and this is it. Hello once again
pastors. I've been wondering this for
some time now and I figured that it
would be a good question to ask. The
question is how can I better contemplate
Christ and what he has done? How can I
fill my mind with thoughts from above
rather than fill my mind with thoughts
from earth?
I've seen many times that I get am
caught up in thinking about things that
don't elevate the name of God. So
instead of thinking those things, I want
to fill my mind with Christlike
thoughts. Thanks Andrew. What a
wonderful question. Person who has a
desire to uh you know fill the mind with
Jesus Christ. So amen. So how does the
person do this?
Well, well first of all to have pure
thoughts there is a part that we need to
do and is to clear our minds from
whatever enters into our mind.
So uh one thing God is not going to do
for you what you can do for yourself.
Mhm.
So if you're listening to worldly music
or watching things worldly things on
television on on your phone or if you
are delighting in seeing or listening to
certain things that do not uplift then
you you need to begin by cutting those
things because um you can you can follow
the counselss that we're going to give
you right now from the word of God but
as unless you cut that then you won't be
as successful.
in having pure thoughts.
Yeah.
Uh Philippians 4:8.
Um this is what the apostle Paul says.
Actually the whole book of Philippians
has to do with uh the mind. Philippians
chapter 4:E8.
Here the Bible says, "Finally, brethren,
whatsoever things are true, whatever
things are noble, whatever things are
just, whatever things are pure, whatever
things are lovely, whatever things are
of good report, if there is any virtue,
and if there is anything praiseworthy,
meditate on these things." And I like
how the King James says it, think of
these things.
Yeah. Um, and you know, we could also
add 2 Corinthians 3:18,
correct?
Uh, which is one of my favorite verses
because of a particular word that is
used here. The Apostle Paul wrote, "But
we all with unveiled face,
beholding
as in a mirror the glory of the Lord,
that means his character, are being
transformed,
amen,
into the same image from glory to glory
just as by the spirit of the Lord." Uh
that word transformed
is the Greek word metamorpho where we
get the word metamorphosis uh from. What
is a metamorphosis? It is a radical
change.
That's right.
I mean, it's used for example of a
butterfly. Now, butterfly isn't born a
butterfly. Butterfly is born a
caterpillar
and then the caterpillar through a
process becomes a butterfly. You say,
"How did that happen?" Well, it's a
metamorphosis. And so, by beholding,
we go through a metamorphosis in our
spiritual life. Also we have u the book
of Hebrews uh the book of Hebrews uh
chapter 12 after mentioning all of the
heroes of faith in chapter 11 it says
therefore we also since we are
surrounded by so great a cloud of
witnesses let us lay aside every weight
and the sin that so easily ens snares
us. This is the point that you were
making and that is that first of all we
have to pre prevent evil from coming
into our minds and we have to fill our
minds with the good.
And so it continues saying um and let us
run with endurance the race that is set
before us. How do we do that? Looking
unto Jesus.
Amen. the author and finisher of our
faith, who for the joy that was set
before him, endured the cross, despising
the shame, and sat down at the right
hand of the throne of God. For consider
him who endured such hostility from
sinners against himself, lest you become
weary and discouraged in your souls. So
in other words, it is once again by
running the race, looking unto Jesus
with our eyes looking at Jesus that we
overcome sin.
Amen. Now Psalm 119 verse9 it says
wherewith all shall a young man cleanse
his way
by taking heed thereto according to thy
word. So fill your mind with the word of
God. Uh memorize scripture that's going
to help you a lot.
And um
a key word from 2 Corinthians 3:18 also
by beholding we become changed. And um I
don't I won't have the time to read this
quote, but in Desire of Ages uh page 83,
she says, "It would be well to spend a
thoughtful hour each day in
contemplation of the life of Christ. Uh
take it point by point and let the
imagination grasp each scene, especially
the closing ones." So I would highly
recommend that you read the Desire of
Ages, especially focus on the last
scenes of Jesus Christ. That's how you
behold Jesus Christ today in his word,
in the spirit of prophecy. And by
beholding you will become changed. Your
imagination will be purified and will be
cleansed after the righteousness of
Jesus.
And that solitary hour would be good to
spend in a solitary place without any
distractions. Well, time is up. God
bless you. Hope to see you next time.
[Music]